I think you you play Jesus Christ hello
welcome to the show method my name is
Sean McGuinness and I've gone through
some medical procedures which have made
me 50% more Irish and I previously was
and now I'm gonna spell my name s EI n
MC oh oh god the the the dupe is up I
love about this game is have like so
obvious I get liberated numerators
[ __ ] hate modern video games the save
option is unavailable during missions
all right let me quit the [ __ ]
mission there nope mission failed great
save now nope gonna shoot me back to the
start of the mission great oh this is
suppose to be me trolling the game not
being trolled by the game leave this
right here great hooray it's super easy
to be stealthy in this game oh I just
threw a harsh for some reason you don't
know Bo oh it's so opiates ridiculous
afterlife
Pam what the [ __ ] is that a snake Jesus
that's not shark a shark oh wait [ __ ]
you that's a again and again oh I'm not
shoot this can I back out of this a back
out of shooting this weapon - please
please video game no it doesn't Marco
that dudes in a head like killing
witches armies of Daft Punk
impersonators are almost there this
looks like the end if ever I've seen it
oh it's this pen with the [ __ ] blog
right this is this is why I didn't
complete it because of these sons of
[ __ ]
Oh Kelly Kelly Kelly Kelly Kelly either
weak points trying to get them to [ __ ]
off so I can put some lines and oh for
God's sake shoot you in your sternum
I'll just reach out to level again all
of the eggs are going on one basket over
Neath up parts of jerk
perfect
omma dick they'll hold white to heal I'm
holding why I could not be holding Y
anymore
[ __ ] this game god damn it who's calling
who Shawn method it's all brought to you
by the good folks at Ubisoft - a
broken-ass game delivery service I'm
gonna go hunting something is much more
relaxing than having to kill those
pricks hey what's up dudes
hey I didn't all right sorry
all right all right what a lot of
Beefalo
order all these guys between your but
these are you invincible die and like I
probably better go in for this where the
most live arrived again get ready go
around in circles
told you I'm not in a mission I didn't
accept the [ __ ] mission don't do it
automatically
videogames we're gonna have to define
the mission again and you're gonna
transport me somewhere else got down
with Far Cry 3 blood dragon god dammit
I'm sorry guy you guys know what a goats
are all I want as it goes so many dead
men and all I want as it goes it's just
like that a lot of smarts that song
here's it go alright okay eight animals
out of 12 killed
that's why I've left to do for neon
snake Robo croc I'm pretty sure I killed
one of those mutated Turtles do you
abort walk yeah you're AB or nine or
twelve animals kills dawn he now is
snake and title get turtle snakes are
pretty small
alright the head no you're in our jetski
whenever I think it's a turtle it's a
jetski
you guys see a turtle and it looks like
a little grenade yeah like a big grenade
face like a grin over to face Buffalo a
grenade I just threw it the Buffalo
floating Buffalo elk you blow dragons no
pores but I think you know knife oh [ __ ]
no I meant up yours you want to play you
want to play your whole family
ah
rating me tonight
not at the end of this week's episode of
Shama that apologies its advance to
everyone actually I'm gonna take partial
doing for this I'm gonna lay the rest on
the good folks and you play or chewing
off my far cry 3 Steam sale code how
dare they
well I raced all that money on the Steam
sale I want to at least play one of the
eight games I bought safely larger I'll
never get to play any of these others
that's far out of your blood dragon
which is also on the Steam sale or at
least was when I picked it up and will
probably be on the Steam sale again
because there's a lot of the repeat
offers popping up all the time but yeah
that's it Shaw McKenna's we back on Shaw
method next week